- I love your outfit.
- Thank you.
- So wait, I have to say this,
you have a new addition since
the last time we talked.
You have a little one now.
- I have a baby, yes.
Cosmo, he's about, I think
15 months old, 14 months.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's exciting.
- The whole months thing
has alluded me.
- [Kelly] I know, but you
still get the baby smell.
Mine are six and eight, so I
don't have baby smell anymore.
That's so cute.
- Oh, yeah, baby smell,
you wanna just bottle it.
- Skin on skin, and you just take them in.
- Delicious.
- I love it.
How did you come up with the name Cosmo?
- Oh, gosh.
Yeah, we just threw a
bunch of letters together.
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, that works.
(Kelly and Scarlett laugh)
- Yeah, it just seemed like a really...
I just thought it was so charming.
And then, our friends all liked it.
And then Colin's mom
had a little bit of a harder time with it.
She was like, "This seems kind of..."
It wasn't sitting.
She kept suggesting other
versions of it for a while.
And I was like, "No, he's
already here, he's out already."
- [Kelly] It's the name.
- I was like, "It's past that time."
- [Kelly] Gonna have to
own it at this point.
I love that though.
'Cause your daughter's Rose?
- Yes.
- My daughter's River Rose,
that's the only reason why I knew that.
But also, I love that
they're both flowers.
- They are both flowers.
I love...
My kids hate plants of
how much I love them.
- [Scarlett] Oh really?
- And flowers, yeah.
They're like, "Oh good, plants."
But I love flowers and plants
and I thought that was kind of cool.
- Yeah.
Not a lot of people make that connection,
but yeah, Cosmo's a really
sweet little flower,
comes in different shades of orange
and yellow and stuff like that,
that's why my daughter liked it too.
- [Kelly] See, they're both flowers.
But also I wanna talk about this,
'cause last time we talked about music
because I love your tone.
- [Scarlett] That's very kind.
- [Kelly] Would you ever
release more music?
- [Scarlett] Oh gosh, I don't know.
I know I...
I honestly, for me,
the greatest joy I have is
doing all the Sing movies.
- I love you in Sing.
- Thank you.
Yeah, they're just so much fun.
And so hopefully there'll
be another Sing movie
that will come out and I'll get to...
Last time I got to partner with Bono,
which was insane.
- Wow!
- [Scarlett] It was ridiculous.
We got to duet.
We did "Stuck in a Moment" together.
- Oh I know.
- Oh, yeah.
- I have children, we've seen...
And honest to God, even
if they leave the room,
I still watch it.
- Yeah, those movies are really-
- [Kelly] They're good!
- They're for everybody!
They're such great family movies,
but that would be my next foray,
would be if we hopefully would
ever do another Sing movie,
which, hoping maybe we would do.
- [Kelly] And it's fun work to do,
to just show up and just get in the studio
and create these characters just by audio.
- [Scarlett] Yeah, I
love doing voice work.
I've done films where I just
did voice work for the whole...
It's really interesting to not...
As an actor, you have your physicality
and then you have your voice,
and when you don't have
one of those things,
everything becomes much more intense.
- [Kelly] Intense.
- Yeah.
And it's interesting.
You get to play with the,
well, that's all your job,
but you get to play with
all the different intonation
and nuance in your vocal
performance in a really...
- And now your voice sounds
different in different tone.
- Yeah, that's fun to do.
- It is fun.
- Do you sing around the house?
Does Colin sing?
Do y'all ever sing together?
I feel like your house would be fun.
(Scarlett and Kelly laugh)
- [Scarlett] Yeah, I mean, Colin, he...
- [Kelly] Oh, you're being polite.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, what am I sensing?
Oh, that's being polite.
Colin's tone death.
(Scarlett and Kelly laugh)
- No, he "sings."
He played-
(Kelly laughs)
He does sing.
He was in Fiddler On the Roof,
four times in high school.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- So that's...
- Why was he in it four times?
- Yeah, why did they do it so many times?
- Exactly, or did they only get the rights
to the one musical and they just kept...
- He also went to a Catholic high school-
- [Kelly] Interesting!
- So it's also strange
that they did so many productions
of Fiddler On the Roof
- [Kelly] That is interesting.
- [Scarlett] Which
traditionally is not done
with a Catholic...
(Scarlett and Kelly laugh)
- [Kelly] It makes it-
- Appropriation.
- [Kelly] Does he ever
try out jokes on you
and then you're like, "No?"
- Yes, definitely.
- I love that.
- There's a lot of times where I'm like,
it's not now...
He'll love a play on words
or a pun, just really-
- [Kelly] Dad joke?
- [Scarlett] Yeah.
That have now become dad jokes,
they used to be just duds
and now they're dads.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's the elevated step up.
- [Scarlett] Yeah.
We do have a...
My daughter loves to sing.
And she sings, she loves to make up songs
and their very stream of consciousness.
- [Kelly] That's my daughter.
- [Scarlett] Yeah.
And some of them are really...
They'll give you kind of a
key into what she's thinking,
which is really kind of...
- Can it get dark in your house?
'Cause all of a sudden
she'll say something
and I'm like, "What?"
- What?
- Yeah, my kids are really interested
and scared about death right now.
- Oh yeah, that age.
- They don't understand.
My six year old is like,
"Why do I only get one life?"
And I'm just like,
wow, I just didn't know that
was gonna be a question.
(laughs)
- Did you explain the Metaverse though?
- [Kelly] And then I was like...
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
They weren't ready.
I'm not ready, Scarlett.
People keep trying to explain it to me.
And I'm like, "What?"
- I feel like a six year
old would understand.
- Better than me, yes.
I think that's the truth.
So before the break,
(audience cheers)
we were talking about singing
and I did not know this,
so Katy Perry song, "I Kissed a Girl,"
you're the muse for that?
- That is what I have heard.
I feel like that's a
crossword puzzle question.
- [Kelly] That's incredible!
- Yes.
I also heard that too,
but it's not been confirmed-
- [Kelly] We're going to need that-
- From Katy Perry herself.
I don't think so.
- [Kelly] Okay.
If she could just call in anytime now.
(Kelly laughs)
- Actually, we have Katy Perry.
No, just kidding.
(Kelly and Scarlett laugh)
I just thought, I was like,
I didn't know that, that's incredible,
that was a massive hit.
What a muse you are!
- I will say this,
'cause it's "I kissed
a girl and I liked it,"
that didn't happen,
I've never kissed Katie Perry.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Not that I know of, anyway.
(audience laughs)
- Men's dreams just died everywhere.
(Kelly and Scarlett laugh)
It's fine.
- I mean, it was the odds,
so maybe I did.
- Maybe in the Metaverse.
I don't understand it, still.
I heard this was true too,
that you once tweezed your
friend's eyebrows completely off.
- [Scarlett] Okay, first of all,
it was the 90s.
(Kelly laughs)
No one had eyebrows.
So I would say she was pretty
pleased with the results,
'cause she was like,
"Great, I have no eyebrows,
" like Drew Barrymore
and all those other girls
"that were like..."
- [Kelly] Did I miss this phase?
I don't remember a phase where people-
- [Scarlett] What?
- Got rid of their eyebrows.
- [Scarlett] Yes, it was like that thing
where you had these 20s,
little round eyebrows.
- [Kelly] I'm not cool.
I'm not a member of any cool club.
(Kelly laughs)
- I've got some tweezers back.
- Nope.
(Scarlett and Kelly Laugh)
But did they grow back?
- Hers did not grow back as
we wanted them to as much,
I would say.
- [Kelly] Oh no!
- But at the time they were cute,
now, more, I'd say patchier.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- Oh my God.
- [Scarlett] Now there's
all kinds of serums
you can use though.
Whatever, she asked me to do it.
- [Kelly] Well, here is a segue, serums.
You have a new skincare line.
- That's very smooth.
- [Kelly] See, there you
go, I'm working on it.
It's called The Outset.
So let's bring it out.
Justin has it right here.
- It's called The Outset.
- Why did you name it The Outset?
Look how carefully you're doing that.
- Oh my gosh, this is
such a beautiful display.
- Yes!
- And I feel like...
- You can turn it around.
- Oh my God, it spins!
- Yes, we're very fancy.
This is season four,
season four.
- [Scarlett] I feel like
I'm on the home shopping
network right now.
(Kelly laughs)
So this is The Outset,
I've been working on this
skincare line for over five years.
- Wow!
- And we really,
this is your return to
essential, everyday skincare.
And the way we came up with the name,
is we kept thinking about,
what's at the start?
We really believe in this
idea of new beginnings
and starting afresh.
And then it was like,
and it's at the outset of your day.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thought, well, this is cute,
this is working.
- That's cool,
I like the name.
- Thank you.
It has been a labor of love.
And, I mean,
it's something that I am
incredibly passionate and proud of.
- [Kelly] I am incredibly
picky with skincare
'cause I'm allergic to life.
So when-
- This is-
- What sets apart?
Why should I use yours, 'cause
I'm excited to use yours,
'cause I'm stealing
this and taking it home,
by the way.
- [Scarlett] Yes.
And there's this wonderful display
you could also-
- I'm gonna take
the whole thing.
- I think skincare has
just become so complicated
and there's a lot of
steps in these routines
and there are very
active ingredients and I-
- There's so many steps,
it's kind of hard, yeah.
- It's crazy.
And your skin gets,
skin sensitivities on the rise.
And a lot of it's self-inflicted
because we're using all these products
that clash against one another.
I think that, for me, ive
always had sensitive skin,
I've had acne prone skin,
- [Kelly] Me too, cystic.
Ugh.
- [Scarlett] Yeah, me too.
And I noticed that when I was
just going back to the basics
and using this very simple routine
of cleansing and prepping and moisturizing
and just putting moisture back in,
it actually like made my
skin look healthy and clear.
And I couldn't find that
on the market anywhere,
that was a transparent line,
a clean skincare line
made for sensitive skin.
We're fragrance free, nut allergen free,
gluten free, cruelty free, all of it.
- And it's effective, which
is a tough thing to do.
We definitely set the bar
high for ourselves, but I'm-
- [Kelly] That's awesome-
- Incredibly proud of it.
- [Kelly] That you took the time, though.
You took the time to make it right.
- [Scarlett] A lot of time.
I did it myself,
it's something that I felt
like I wanted to do something
that really...
I'm a little bit of a control freak,
and I wanted to make sure
that I saw through the entire
project and was really proud.
- Your name's associated with it.
- [Scarlett] It's my name.
- It's your product.
- [Scarlett] It's my product
It's something that's been,
like I said, a labor of love,
but I really can say that I
stand fully behind this line.
I think the simplicity and ease of it
is what makes it stand apart.
- I'm trying it.
- [Scarlett] I'm very excited for you.
It's made for sensitive skin.
- [Kelly] And that's me.
- [Scarlett] Yes.
- And my poor children.
Sorry, genetics.
(Scarlett laughs)